the battle for the capital continues
with daily shelling that includes
residential buildings from russian
positions just 15 kilometers away
and closer quarters fighting on its
suburban outskirts western intelligence
assessments point to ground offensives
that have largely stalled with russian
troops making little or no progress
towards strategic objectives
but if towns like urpin butcher and
hostimel were to fall a path could open
up for a push into key of itself
in the meantime the major centres of
this conflict continue to get pounded
from artillery positions and from the
air yet more residential buildings hit
in kharkiv
and cherniv
and russia maintains its stranglehold of
mariupol in the south
a convoy of vehicles was able to leave
the besieged port city on monday but no
aid supplies made it in
the resumption of ceasefire talks on
tuesday may result in a more sustained
local ceasefire around paul
where it's clear relief cannot come too
soon
[Music]
hundreds of thousands of people are
trapped in conditions of unimaginable
hardship in a city blockaded and
bombarded for two weeks bodies are said
to lie uncollected in the street
supplies of food water and medicine near
exhausted
ukraine's president zielenski has urged
russian troops to surrender
on behalf of the ukrainian people we
give you a chance to live if you
surrender to our forces we will treat
you as humans have to be treated with
dignity the way you have not been
treated by your own army and the way
your army does not treat our people
choose
so a second day of cease-fire talks and
separately an adviser to president
zielenski has said he believes the war
will be over by may at the very latest a
prediction based on intelligence reports
of slower than expected russian progress
larger than expected russian losses its
forces spread increasingly thinly across
the vastness of north south and eastern
ukraine
wishful thinking perhaps
the units of the people's militia of the
donets republic continued to compress
the encirclement in mario paul the
general advance from the east the
northern and western direction was up to
800 meters the divisions of the russian
armed forces are continuing offence of
operations
there are reports that russia has
already prevailed on allies like china
and syria for help
but all the heart in this fight belongs
to ukraine
and it refuses to submit
jonah al jazeera love
imran khan said one of the apartment
buildings in kiev that was hit and he
spoken with one of his residents
this is what it's like to be inside one
of the apartments in this bombed out
building which happened in the early
hours of the morning this actually a
child's room marsha
is the kid that normally lives here
she's actually been evacuated but you
can see the windows the power of the
blast blew the windows in they've
actually managed to tidy up a lot of the
glass get it all out a lot of the the
kids books and things are now actually
on the balcony there's still a lot of
damage here
this is vatislav who lives here vacilla
just tell us what happened in the
morning uh
5
early in the morning
we listened a very big boom and
uh smell of gunpowder and
we sleeping on corridor
like every seventy nights nights and
i'm
jump on this place and saw absolutely
the damage
room with broken window glass
all the way and
it was very
i was very afraid and
but i try
being
absolutely
[Music]
calm yeah yeah acclaim yeah and
because i understand my girlfriend was
very afraid and almost
hysteric
and i must be cla
claim and
i'm starting to
collect
our things staff for
going out
to the street
a very traumatic experience you now you
said that you've been sleeping in the
corridor rather than the bedrooms were
you told to do that or is this something
you felt like you had uh it was
sleeping every
night and corridor it was
like
self-defense
because we understand it's a war and
bombing
can
happen every time
because we
absolutely with clothes with shoes
with
our
[Music]
baggage for
south
for something yeah
well it's lucky that you were in the
corridor a lot of people in these
apartments are actually sleeping in
their corridors precisely because
they're afraid of an attack like this
well that's a situation in the capital
cave but odessa is one of the cities
along the southern coast that's still
under you can ukrainian control but the
russian military is approaching our
correspondent
hamid is there um talk to us about what
things are like in this city
well certainly you can see from the
picture
behind me here this is a fortified city
this is a city that has actually
been hit on the first night of the war
on february 24th 20 people died
on that day
and it is a city that president vladimir
zedenski had warned more than once that
russia is planning to attack it is a
very strategic port city on the black
sea one of the most important ports
for ukraine a lot of uh exports happen
from that city and as you mentioned uh
there is a russian advance to the south
of odessa and the russian uh troops are
still stuck in nico mikalayev but that's
only about 130 kilometers from here now
the ukrainians say that at the moment
they controlled the n24 which is the
road that would lead from nicolaive to
odessa but odessa as odessa feels that
it's not under pressure from this
advance from the south uh they could
there's also the fact that it's facing
the black sea the the ukrainians are
saying that the russians are fortifying
or building up their navel positions in
the sea that the the city could be
attacked from the sea as well and then
some do also say that a third front
could be open from across the border in
moldova from that breakaway region of
transnistria which is of course
pro-russian so
it's a city that feels that it could
become very quickly under siege and it's
actually throughout my travels in this
country it is one of the most fortified
cities i've seen so far
part of behind those fortifications how
are people coming to terms with the fact
that the russian military could be
approaching and their lives could
significantly change
well i would say that more than half of
the population has already
left odessa now what's very interesting
about this place this is a city that was
openly pro-russian this is a city where
after the annexation of crimea back in
2014
uh that saw riots between the
pro-ukrainian
youth and
pro-russian youth and those were deadly
riots about 40
people died at the time and this is also
a city that has a lot of russian
investment
tourists from russia come here all the
time so it's always a city that has seen
itself like that now wherever since
we've arrived here really from the
checkpoints at the entrance of the city
with that very heavy security all we
have seen are ukrainian flags i was
speaking to a young man earlier and i
said to him well do you think that
russia wants orders they said of course
russia wants odessa because of all these
investments because of all these
factories that are here all that russian
money that's here because of his
strategic point but he also said that
many of the pro-russians who were here
were horrified
uh not only about what is unfolding in
kiev but what it happened in another
city considered very much per russian
kharkim and i asked do you think this
would happen here with russia destroy
odessa which is sort of considered the
jewel of the black sea and he said i
have no doubt they would destroy it if
we don't give in but from what i've seen
around we've been here only a few hours
this is a city that is now showing the
ukrainian colors supporting the
ukrainian colors and very much backing
ukraine
abdulhamid talking to us from odessa
harder thank you